for the first time in decades hira lala
is feeling optimistic
the kashmiri hindu fled with his family
from indian administered kashmir in 1990
because of religious violence he's
pleased with the indian government's
decision to revoke the region's autonomy
under article 370 but has his concerns
if we are we are supposed to go back
to there where shall we leave where is
our home
what is our livelihood what shall we
earn
and shall we be saved there
who will look after us and who is
who will be a governor for our safety
there
india's home minister led tuesday's
charge for change in the lower
house of parliament where the bill
passed easily thanks to the government's
majority
and support from the opposition members
but many members of parliament say
support for india in the kashmir valley
has dried up
following the government's revoking of
the region's autonomy and splitting it
into two federal territories
even those who politically supported the
indian government in the region are now
lashing out
this is not india that i believe in
my india is india
or india for all whatever your religion
whatever your region these students
studying near new delhi are worried
they've been scrambling to find a way to
contact their families and friends in
indian administered kashmir
without much success my main concern
that are my parents even okay
like are they even i don't know are they
even alive
being away from home and not knowing
what they are going through
and when you have been a part of it
already in the past so i know what are
the problems
but this is the like highest this is the
worst kind of situation that has
happened in kashmir till now
as many worry about their families and
kashmir being cut off
others are dreaming of a new beginning
there
is jameel al-jazeera new delhi